au niveau des centres culturels
périphériques s'agissant de centres qui
sont vraiment au contact du quartier
nous avons nous avons privilégié la
proximité donc les personnes
responsables des sites ont elles mêmes
évaluer l'ampleur de la demande pour la
reprise façon à dimensionner les cours
mais que ce soit en périphérie ou aux
simples
nous avons tenu compte pour la
répartition des personnes dans les
salles des préconisations en matière de
distanciation en matière de respect des
protocoles sanitaires
donc il ya eu quand on va dire droit
commun et
étant donné que nous avons pour chaque
site des salles dynamique
dimensions différentes donc nous avons
adapté de la signalétique au terrain